welcome back to sunday night in america
joe manchin is a united states senator
from west virginia
he's been in office for about a decade
he's become one of the more influential
people in all of politics
seemingly with control over a
president's agenda
the u.s senate is split 50-50 with a
50-50 senate any senator
could be powerful but the democrats have
a vice president vice president harris
as a tiebreaker
so they don't need defections from
republicans to pass bills
they just need to keep all the democrats
singing from the same hymnal
and lately that's been a problem uh
specifically joe manchin
has been a problem and that has made
many in the media and some on the left
very animated
sometimes i wonder if the media and some
on the left
know what state joe manchin represents
it's west virginia the same west
virginia that voted for donald trump
twice with almost 70 percent of the vote
the same west virginia that has voted
for the republican candidate for
president
in every presidential race this century
democrats have won in west virginia
before michael dukakis
actually beat george h.w bush in west
virginia in 1992
and bill clinton won in west virginia
twice so
west virginia does know how to vote for
democrats
they just haven't been doing it much
lately west virginia
is a republican state now all three
members of the house of representatives
from west virginia are republicans
the west virginia state house and state
senate are controlled by republicans
and the governor is a republican i did
not do
well in math but i did okay in logic
joe manchin is the only democrat in an
otherwise republican state
and when i say republican state i mean
neither joe biden or hillary clinton
even
got 30 percent of the vote in west
virginia
let that sink in the last two democrat
candidates for president
did not even get 30 percent of the vote
in west virginia so is the media
really surprised that joe manchin is not
going for
packing the supreme court is the left
really surprised that joe manchin
is not going to vote for a federal
takeover
of state elections or d.c statehood or
ending the filibuster
is the media really surprised that joe
manchin is not
really big on the paris climate accord
he's a democrat in a heavily republican
state
i thought senators were supposed to be
the voice for the people who elected
them
i thought senators were supposed to vote
the way their constituents wanted them
to vote
i thought that was the whole purpose of
having a representative democracy
it may well be that joe manchin doesn't
believe what is being advocated for
on the left these days it is most
assuredly true that the people he
represents do not believe
in it joe manchin is the last democrat
standing in an
otherwise ruby red state
would the media prefer there be no
democrats left standing in west virginia
would they prefer control of the united
states senate go to the republicans
maybe the media is right maybe joe
really is a republican and should switch
sides is that
really what you want washington post
the media and the hard left are welcome
to be disappointed in joe manchin
but it's a little naive to act surprised
joe biden lost every single county in
west virginia
so why would joe manchin help pass an
agenda that lost
every single county in the state he is
supposed to represent
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else